now  a famed nevada aviator known for his  world records and his ufo activism has  died john lear passed away in his sleep  tuesday night in his las vegas home  that's according to lear's daughter  allison he was 79. now lear is the son  of bill lear who developed the lear jet  the son though carved out his own path  setting multiple world records as an  aviator during the vietnam era he flew  cargo planes for the c.i.a then in the  1980s lear became an outspoken critic of  an alleged government cover-up of ufos  his interviews here on channel 8 were  seen all over the world  lear's friendship with a scientist named  bob lazar helped put the area 51  military base on the map